t'as vu tu vois jamais vas-y alors du
coup j'avoue du coup un petit que c'est
quelque chose auquel je ne réfléchis pas
que jeudi malgré moi et le jour où mon
pote me dis vas tu as vu ta 10 10 fois
en mode nous mettre un joueur a été de
dire et là tu y arrives pas il ya une
étude de harvard qui a été publié en
qui dit qu' un locuteur moyens il a 5
tick par minute quand même un tout et 12
secondes ça vient du mot ticket au en
l'italien hockey au xviie siècle qui
arrive en france et c'est d'abord un
spasme involontaire du cheval en fête le
tic c'est une sorte d' euros c'est le
cheval qui rote et alors c'est vrai
qu'au début on a tendance à oublier mais
c'est vrai que le tic c'est aussi la
personne qui a un peu du mal à
s'exprimer qui aimerait dire quelque
chose mais qui cherche qui fait tu vois
voilà donc ça ressemble à une sorte de
régurgitation un peu linguistique
c'est un moment en tout cas où le sens
et la syntaxe
si vous voulez le servent un peu à rien
c'est à un moment où on utilise un autre
mot qui va pas apporter une information
du tout donc il va vraiment montré un
locuteur qui est en train de discuter
avec quelqu'un qui est en train
d'essayer d'attirer son attention de la
garder en fait il ya certains tics qui
apparaissent à certains moments et y
révèle quand même quelque chose dans
notre rapport à la réalité
alors moi par exemple en vrai de base
c'est d'éthique qui sont super fréquent
en ce moment depuis trois ans à ses
récents vraiment et je les interprète
mois comme montrant notre besoin de se
réaffirmer comme appartenant à une vie
réelle quoi par opposition à la vie
virtuelle de tous les réseaux sociaux
donc en vrai bah ouais en vrai j'ai
besoin de dire que attend il ya aussi
une vie une réalité qui n'est pas celle
des écrans qui n'est pas celle
d'internet qui n'est pas celle du
fantasme de main de mon image un peu se
sublimer avec filtre est tous sur
instagram et donc je dire en vrai tout
le temps en vrai c'est un peu voyez
c'est un peu jones nokia en jogging quoi
c'est en vrai c'est dans la vraie vie
ouf oui on a des tics de langage
maintenant c'est vrai qu'ils sont plus
ou moins fréquent quand même les jeunes
entendent avoir un peu plus 2 par ce
désir de sociabilité par ce facteur qui
est aussi le désir de ressemblance de
mimétisme on retrouve dans le type qu'on
attrape vraiment est aussi le ticket
vecteur vraiment d'agrégation c'est à
dire qu'on va dire frères ou en mode
parce que nos potes le disais que c'est
cool et on s'inscrit comme de rien
besoin d'inscription dans un groupe
socioculturel qui trahit bas qui est
forcément un peu plus fort à
l'adolescence jeunes adultes où il ya
une quête un peu d'identité quoi donc on
affirme peut-être un peu plus son
identité avec ses tics et puis à
l'humour y est la cria utilité tout
simplement il ya plus d'entousiasme donc
qui diffuse enthousiasme dit plus de
l'adverbe intensif plus de d'expression
du plus haut degré en fait c'est mortel
c'est une tueriie chiant pls ou en bd r
c'est tout des expressions qui disent en
fait le haut degré avant 17 heures
dans les années 60 mongin peu plus jeune
que ça mais apparemment les générations
au dessus de moi disait c'est top set up
et c'était ça le tic quoi donc oui c'est
là bas c'est la jeunesse qui est force
de renouvellement du langage et de qui
le bouscule un peu j'ai l'impression
qu'on est à un moment linguistique assez
nouveau qui a une telle production de
discours en fait visible sur les réseaux
sociaux en même temps avec intel
une telle amplitude dans ceux qui
regardent ce qui lie ce qu'ils
réagissent que pour la première fois on
a un passage une transition d'une forme
écrite à une forme orale
donc on va les avoir mdr que qu'on peut
retrouver à l'oral beau gosse bg qui a
été de mouture d'acronymes qui devient
tavus bg à l'oral
en france on juge beaucoup plus
qu'ailleurs le tic
pourquoi j'ai en belgique j'avais ces
discussions il est comme un bel je lis
ma personne dit c'est un tic de langage
j'ai vécu en angleterre et aux
etats-unis du jamais j'ai entendu ce
type de remarques il ya qu'en france
quoi pourquoi parce que le bon le
français à l'esprit critique c'est connu
et puis on est élevé qu'en mai dans une
sorte de mythologie esthétisante du
français comme langue pure long de
langue qu'il faut préserver et à
l'académie française tout ça ce qui est
du bullshit donc et en fait elle est pas
plus pur que les autres elle et elle vit
et incorporer des mots c'est une forme
de vie donc nous il faut pas juger de
toute façon d'appeler un tic de langage
un tic de langage c'est quand même déjà
un peu stigmatisés et dire tu vois tu
utilises quelque chose dans une
fréquence qui est trop élevé et et moi
ça me dérange
alors finalement si on est entre copains
à dire tous mille fois en mode en vrai à
la base tu as vu bah tout va bien et
personne ne va vous voyez n'est pas
conclure qu'il faut se débarrasser de
ces petits de langage affreux